the American people need to know whether
the Russians still have something they
can hold over the presidents had the
President of the United States so our
work is far from done I can certainly
say with confidence that there is
significant evidence of collusion
between the campaign and Russia it's 14
months what is it
all right here what the answer the host
of CRT TVs Levin TV and the host of the
number-one show three weekends in a row
in its timeslot very proud of my buddy
the great one Mark Levin thank me how am
I look this guy has been lying to this
country for well over a year mark 14
Megan McCain destroyed him your thoughts
well my thoughts are this mr. Schiff is
a shill for the Russian government and
I'm going to tell you why it is Schiff
who's a propagandist for the Russian
government despite his spinning on all
these left-wing TV shows he put out a
list of 30 more interviews he wants to
do even though the Republicans on the
committee said there's no collusion and
he mentions a long list
Reince Priebus steven miller katie
mcfarland Sean Spicer Kellyanne Conway
bunch of consultants people with the
Trump Organization some of trumps
lawyers somebody that runs the group
Christian rights activists of course he
wants Donald Trump jr. to kick around he
wants Jared Kushner to kick around
family members on and on and on let me
tell you who he doesn't want let me tell
you who this shell for Russia doesn't
want he doesn't want Hillary Clinton he
didn't say we should subpoena Hillary
Clinton even though it was the Hillary
Clinton campaign that laundered money
through a law firm in this Fusion GPS to
do what to corroborate and collude with
the Russians with their phony dossier he
didn't ask for a single Hillary Clinton
campaign official why is that mr. Schiff
since we know they colluded he didn't
ask for the former head of the DNC I
don't know if that was Wasserman Schultz
or Donna Brazile he doesn't want to
subpoena them and question them
where did their money come from that
money that they laundered through that
law firm diffusion GPS to the Russians
that's something he doesn't want to talk
about I've got more Barack Obama how can
it possibly be that the President of the
United States under whom all this
occurred Donald Trump is a candidate
Donald Trump was a victim his family was
victimized Barack Obama was President of
the United States when the Russians were
interfering with our election don't we
the American people want to hear from
Barack Obama in an Open Committee
hearing well mr. Schill for the Russian
ship he doesn't
what about Loretta Lynch and her role on
the face of warrants as Attorney General
she's not on his list neither are other
senior Justice Department officials in
the Obama administration what about
these fights the court judges who even
now know as a matter of fact that what
was presented to them to issue a warrant
against an American citizen was
materially false because it omitted
everything I just told you about the
dossier now what else is it mr. Schiff
interested in he's not interested in
uranium one he doesn't make a single
request for a witness or a subpoena 20%
of America's uranium is now controlled
by Vladimir Putin because she'll shift
is a shill for Putin in my view what
else doesn't he want he doesn't want to
hear Bill Clinton testify who got money
from the Russians to give speeches
around the same time he doesn't want
anyone from the Clinton Foundation to
testify any of the senior officials that
foundation made a fortune off the
Russians who else doesn't he want to
testify
he doesn't want senior lawyers at this
law firm Perkins Coie that keeps popping
up through which money was laundered
diffusion GPS and then to the British X
by and then to the Russians to put this
get this dossier together he doesn't
want her and he doesn't want Susan Rice
back now why does anyone Susan Rice back
there's a new book out that says Susan
Rice objected to the cyber security
personnel in the White House who said
hey Susan
the Russians are interfering with our
election and you know what she told them
stand
shouldn't Susan get another invitation
with a subpoena to testify before the
committee apparently not because mr.
Schiff is a shill
who else what about Ben Rhodes the
deputy director the end of the National
Security Council doesn't mr. Schiff want
to know what the Obama National Security
Council know about Russian interference
in our government no he doesn't mention
her at all now let me tell you something
mr. Schiff is not interested in the
abuses of the Feist application process
he's not interested in what the FISA
Court did he's not interested in the
fact that American citizens were spied
on and their names were unmasked he
doesn't ask for any witnesses related to
that none whatsoever
I will tell you this mr. Schiff you're a
leaker let me see the me Senate the
House Intelligence Committee and because
you're on that committee it ought to be
called the house stupid committee you
are the ranking Democrat on that
committee and you said you didn't leak I
have a choice for you mr. Schiff why
don't you take a lie-detector test why
don't you take a lie-detector test
so the American people can be sure that
you all over TV
ubiquitous you might as well be on
airport radar and sonograms you're
everywhere sir and you tell us you don't
leak okay take a lie detector test
because I believe you do
call me leak FBI director deputy FBI
director mccade leaker James clapper
according to a new book National
Intelligence director leaker according
to their own texts mr. stroke head of
counterintelligence leaker his
girlfriend page leaker this has been a
sham from day one
why the hell with the Russians when
Donald Trump is President of the United
States
you think they like them now one under
Hillary Clinton and John Kerry and under
Barack Obama they got Crimea they got
part of the Ukraine they got a big chunk
of Syria they got 20% of our uranium
why the hell would Latimer Putin want
Donald Trump as president of the United
States when he promised to beef up the
United States military and do all the
means necessary to secure this nation I
I couldn't say it any better now the the
next logical point I want to ask you
about Robert Mahler you're right on
every
he just made the fix was in in the
primary that's Democrats they can deal
with their own party the fix we know was
in on the Clinton email investigation
we'll learn more on the IG report she
tried to fix the general election they
paid for Russian and Russian government
lies in propaganda then you've mentioned
the FISA Court issue they lied to FISA
judges and all that you just said why is
it they robert muller hasn't lifted a
finger to go into any of these issues
none of those peoples have been brought
in and what does it say about our
justice I'll tell you why and this got
about I know you watch these programs
and I believe you and your democrat
prosecutors or leakers to mr. Muller I
have a question for you you've asked
repeatedly apparently the Deputy
Attorney General who's the acting
Attorney General in this case rod
Rosenstein to expand your authority to
chase down issues that have nothing to
do a Russian collusion now you're
running around in the Middle East now
you're running around over here now
you're running around over mr. Muller
why haven't you asked mr. Rosenstein
your friend the Deputy Attorney General
the United States to expand your
investigation to include the Hillary
campaign why haven't you asked mr.
Rosenstein to expand your investigation
to look into the Russian apparatchiks
who gave information to a foreign
ex-british spy who was paid through a
longer process by the Hillary Clinton
campaign in the DNC mr. Clouseau how
come you don't look at that how come you
haven't looked at the abuse and
violations your friend mr. Comey and the
former attorney general of the United
States or the FISA Court I'll tell you
why because this guy's a hitman this guy
who got the whole anthrax investigation
wrong and still hasn't apologized to the
man he was chasing and ruined for five
years this man is out to get the
president that's why Inspector Clouseau
bus line of the night great one good to
see you my friend
Sunday nights life Liberty the great one
Levin congrats number one in the ratings
three weekends in a row